in addition to directing blockbuster
films for grownups tim burton has
crafted many movies for the entire
family as he did with corp's bride
while there's plenty for kids to enjoy
in this classic film some of the
material is aimed straight at the adults
in the room
corp's bride is laced with clever witty
humor of the word play variety and on
top of that death features prominently
in the plot which tends to happen more
often than not in the films of tim
burton the man responsible for other
morbid masterpieces like sweeney todd
frankenweenie and of course beetlejuice
but there's one running joke buried in
corpse bride that combines puns and
death references
and it's so subtle that even most adults
wouldn't notice it on the first or
second viewing the plot of the film
involves the premeditated homicide of
emily the corpse bride at the hand of
her evil fiance lord barkus who intends
to kill again
crows can be seen flying about and
lingering throughout the movie
especially when emily is around
and it's not just because these ominous
midnight colored birds effectively add
creepiness and moodiness to the
proceedings
a group of crows is called a murder
after all which is a gag that ties
nicely into the movie's macabre plot
the works of william shakespeare are
more than 400 years old but they
represent the foundation of a lot of
western narrative fiction from movies to
theater to books
plots laid out by the bard recur
throughout endless films as do
individual references to the works
themselves
shakespeare is so influential that
screenwriters in the 21st century can
include a nod
and wide swaths of the audience will get
the illusions but that's because most
adults receive at least an overview of
shakespeare's greatest hits in high
school or college english literature
class
little kids watching a movie like corpse
bride would likely have no clue when
filmmakers deliver a perfect reference
to shakespeare's most famous tragedy
hamlet which is full of foreboding and
the promise of death
come on hamlet [ __ ] up
toward the end of corpse pride lord
barkus tauntingly toasts emily for her
having died without marrying
then in his arrogance he accidentally
drinks from a goblet to poison wine
which had been intended for victor so he
could join emily
in death that's awfully reminiscent of
the accidental poison switcheroo in act
5 of hamlet
the prince seeking vengeance against his
bill and his stepfather claudius is
toasted by his mother with a glass of
wine that claudius poisoned and intended
to give to hamlet for a movie about dead
people corp's bride has a surprisingly
light touch
particularly in its dialogue the script
is bright bouncy and agile and along
those lines it's full of silly puns and
old jokes that any goofy dad would
proudly make his own
for example in the land of the dead
victor meets a short zombified skeleton
dressed in late 18th century military
officer regalia replete with a bicorn
hat and a sword
he's instantly recognizable to adults as
a riff on the french general and
european conqueror napoleon bonaparte
a bit made overwhelmingly clear when his
name is revealed to be general bones
apart
of course adults will get the reference
immediately but it will definitely fly
over the head of most kids
along with plenty of other punny moments
my name
is paul i am the educator
i'll keep an eye out for him where do
you keep the spirits
[Music]
it seems like the people who make movies
that are ostensibly for kids and clearly
marketed to the young ones like to throw
in mildly risky jokes here and there
not only are these little verbal easter
eggs so subtle and specific that
children will have no idea anything
untoward was said
but they feel like a little reward to
adults or parents who dutifully sat
through a movie made for children
forbes bride has a few examples of
innuendo and suggestive dialogue and
some of it is particularly tough for
kids to notice because it's somewhat
error appropriate to the film's
victorian sensibility
for example the everglads look down
their noses at victor van dorten as
family because
although they're wealthy their money
comes from running a canned fish empire
they dismissively call the vandorts fish
merchants and even though that's what
they actually
are it's implied that it's not a
respectable profession particularly
because a few hundred years ago
fishmonger was a euphemism for procurer
or a man who manages ladies of the night
on another occasion victor goes right up
to the edge of making a suggestive
gesture
while practicing his upcoming wedding
vows alone in the forest he gets a
little carried away with himself
with this hand i will cut your
oh goodness no by the time adults get to
the age where they're old enough to
watch corpse bride with their kids
they've absorbed volumes of cultural
history
most grown-ups can recognize references
and allusions to classic movies from
modern filmmakers who are cinema
devotees such as director tim burton
corp's bride is rife with nods to movies
as far back as the 1920s and 1930s
references the average child relatively
new to movie consumption probably
wouldn't be able to spot
in a scene in the lair of elder gut's
neck the character's hand passes by a
candlelit wall
it comprises only about a second of
screen time but it's enough to evoke a
famous shot from the pioneering 1922
vampire movie nosferatu
then in the big musical number remains
of the day the choreography of the
skeletons instantly brings to mind the
vintage creepiness of the bony dancers
from disney's 1929 animated short film
skeleton dance
the routine from corpse bride even
recreates the xylophone gag from the
original cartoon
which for some reason feels much more
disturbing than the modern version
burton also pays homage to his horror
master predecessor alfred hitchcock and
one of his most famous films
the group of crows that look down on
victor recalls the shot of the birds
looking down on tippy hedren's character
in the birds
corpse bride often alludes to the stars
of some of hollywood's most classic
films for example
alfred is an elegant and cultured
skeleton a denizen of the land of the
dead who strikes quite the handsome
figure in his purple jacket
and long thin mustache his living wife
gertrude doesn't recognize him without
his flesh but eventually she makes the
connection
you've been dead for 15 years frankly my
dear
i don't give a damn that's a reference
to the famous kiss offline from the 1939
classic gone with the wind
those timeless words were uttered to
scarlett o'hara by her former love rhett
butler
a character who like alfred sports a
very dapper mustache
one major character in corpse bride is a
full-on imitation of another movie star
of hollywood's golden age
although one who's been relatively
forgotten by the 21st century and
certainly not someone who kids would be
familiar with
in the film a maggot known only as
maggot lives inside the rotting but
living corpse of emily
their relationship is symbiotic in that
he presumably lives off her dead flesh
but also offers her friendship and
guidance
he's a charming and caring little guy
but his small talk could use some work
excuse me you don't know me but i used
to live
in your dead mother maggots is voiced by
anne reitel who delivers a convincing
vocal impersonation of actor peter
laurie co-star of classic films such as
m
the maltese falcon casablanca and
countless others
maggot even resembles the legendary
actor of course laurie might have had a
few
things to say about us comparing him to
a talking maggot
you imbecile you bloated idiot
you stupid father
corpse pride is an animated movie but
unlike traditional hand-drawn disney
movies or the computer-enabled
ultra-realistic pixar style it was
produced by the deliberate and extremely
taxing method of stop-motion animation
it's the same technique that was used
for coraline the fantastic mr fox and of
course the nightmare before christmas
in all of these films each character is
essentially a puppet that needs to be
physically moved for every frame of
filming
this method of animation was pioneered
by special effects legend ray
harryhausen he used stop motion to bring
dozens of characters to life in classic
sci-fi and fantasy films such as 1963's
jason and the argonauts and 1966's 1
million years bc
just to name a couple corp's bride would
most likely never have been possible
without the work and inspiration of
harryhausen so the filmmakers decided to
pay a small tribute to the trailblazing
artist
in the scene where victor sits down to
play the piano he does so on an
instrument purportedly made by
harryhausen
the team who brought corpse bride to
life referenced a number of vintage
films classic movie stars and legendary
directors of yore but they also throw in
some shout outs to projects that hit
closer to home
specifically there are a few illusions
both subtle and unmistakable to the
films of tim burton which adult
audiences might be more likely to notice
than kids would
for one thing corpse bride further
illustrates burton's love for creepy
trees
the burial places for both emily and the
headless horsemen from sleepy hollow
features trees that are extraordinarily
eerie and have a similar look
and there's another corpse bride element
that might seem familiar to burton fans
in the middle of the film venice
everglad mistakenly calls victor by the
wrong name
we shall continue his plan with or
without vincent
victor whatever a lot of moviegoers
might make the same mistake because
victor bears a striking resemblance to
the main character in burton's early
short film vincent
overall corpse bride concerns dead
people taking extreme action amongst
living beings which is more or less the
plot of burton's 1988 film beetlejuice
nor is corpse pride the first burton
project to feature a dog who has seen
better days
his 1984 short film frankenweenie and
the 2012 full-length animated remake of
the same name
are both about a dead dog come back to
life much like how victor is reunited
with his beloved lost pet scraps and
corpse pride
they
[Music]
an adult mindset brings a different
perspective to a film than that of a
child
not only does life experience offer
another point of view but the
intelligence learned just by spending
more time on the planet allows adults to
notice plot holes or character
inconsistencies that would likely not
bother a child audience member one bit
in corp's bride such a problem exists in
the motivations of the film's primary
villain
the loathsome lord barkus he's the
former fiance of the deceased emily
having killed her and robbed her of her
wealth
that becomes his modus operandi to
convince women to marry him stealing
their treasures then killing them
making things even more complicated
victoria's parents prefer the dashing
old presumably moneyed lord barkus to
victor
and they decide to marry off their
daughter to him instead of victor
this is mostly according to barkus's
plan he wants the everglades to allow
him to marry victoria so that he can
cash in on the dowry and then kill
victoria thereafter however the
everglotts are actually broke and they
thought they were the ones going into
the marriage for financial gain
but if lord barkus's grand plan is to
marry for money wouldn't he have
properly researched beforehand to
confirm that the everglades were in fact
wealthy there's a lot of death in corpse
pride although there isn't a lot of
violence
this is a pg-rated movie for families
after all and depicting how the dead
people actually died is largely
inconsequential
still the film does suggest how several
of its deceased characters became
permanent residents of the land of the
dead and decaying
for example the area's barber retrieves
his trusty scissors by pulling them out
of his own head
this implies that he was killed by the
very tools of his trade
then there's the chef who in his
previous life clearly found himself on
the wrong end of some serious kitchen
utensils
as for emily the corpse bride herself
viewers know she was killed by the
greedy and villainous lord barkus but
they aren't made privy as to how exactly
the act went down
however judging from the tear in her
dress the exposed ribs and the moment
where she catches a sword to save victor
we can assume that lord barkus took her
life
by stabbing her through the abdomen
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
animated classics are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one